today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video hope
everybody had a good Memorial Day
weekend coronavirus in popular culture
and in the National Dialogue
is no longer primarily a medical event
over the long weekend that shift has
been completed and what coronavirus now
is is a culture war and this is by
necessity because Donald Trump has
failed on coronavirus from the
standpoint of medical as he might say
and the only way that Donald Trump can
plausibly purport to appear to be
winning maybe maybe is to turn this into
a culture war and he's being assisted in
doing that by the reopen protesters by
the anti-vaxxers by the many others who
are actively contributing to the demise
of the United States the United States
being a laughingstock globally the
pandemic is a disease and it is a
disease prevalent over a whole country
or the world that's what we have in
coronavirus we have a pandemic it is a
medical situation the culture war is a
cultural conflict it is a conflict
between groups social groups typically
sometimes economic groups over values it
is a struggle for the dominance over
values and beliefs and practices and
notice that the primary discussions of
coronavirus as a medical issue have been
forced into irrelevance by this
administration it started of roughly a
month ago when I told you that Donald
Trump is getting away from press
briefings and instead doing the CEO
propaganda events these pseudo rallies
at warehouses that distribute PPE I
think he did one last week or the week
before in Pennsylvania I think it was
and to look at this in a different way
to look at it as a culture war explains
a lot of the nonsense that we're seeing
let me give you an example
churches pushed into phase one in a
number of different states as one of the
first types of entities that will reopen
it's indefensible scientifically but
it's a cultural signal it's a way to
signal signal virtue in a sense and
that's why so many governors have
included houses of worship in phase one
they've been under huge pressure to do
it and this is why Donald Trump is now
making a huge deal out of churches and
I'm gonna deal a little bit later with
the legal aspect of Donald Trump saying
he will force governor's to deem
churches essential but that now is a
culture war around coronavirus Church
isn't going to church masks masks are
now part of the culture war you wouldn't
have thought of a mask as a political
tool six months ago it is strictly
political now for a huge portion of
American society medical issues have
been relegated to irrelevance
discussions of the are not the
reproduction rate of the virus they're
talking about it in Germany Angela
Merkel is talking about it in Germany as
they look to reopen they talked about it
in New Zealand the contagion treatments
and vaccines these things are being
mentioned by Trump only in the context
of continuing to wage the culture war
and in fact even treatment has become an
opportunity to virtue signal do you
blindly follow Trump on
hydroxychloroquine or do you not
regardless of what the science says this
is by design this is the only way that
Donald Trump can sort of continue to
justify his presidency to justify his
reelection or to even have a shot at
that reelection and this is a movement
that has turned a medical incident into
a cultural war the movement understand
is an amalgamation as I wrote on Twitter
yesterday of Trump supporters who just
follow Trump no matter what so-called
libertarians who are just focused on the
so-called Liberty elements which I'll
discuss a little bit later today
anti-vaxxers and conspiracy theorists
there this is a Venn diagram those
groups overlap but they have coalesced
perfectly to pervert the handling
the pandemic as a pandemic as a medical
incident and instead have turned it into
a cultural war by the way why was Donald
Trump the one briefing Americans from
day one anyway or Mike Pence or whoever
it was because of the culture war aspect
of this the way to depoliticize
a pandemic is to do what many countries
have done you have doctors do the
briefings look at how Ebola was handled
back in 2014 in some of the outbreak
countries in Africa public health
officials were the ones communicating
with the public not incompetent
partisans but this is a strategy it's a
concerted effort and the Trump
administration realizes this is their
only shot so they are actively
escalating the culture war component
every time Trump issues a threat about
overriding governor's those are not
medical statements those are not
constitutional statements he actually
can't do it legally and I'll talk about
that in a moment these are merely claims
from Trump to amp up the culture war and
this reminds me more and more over the
cultural battle over a medical procedure
known as abortion and in fact sometimes
it's been mentioned Trump has even
mentioned there are governors saying
abortion clinics are essential but
churches are not that's red meat culture
war language having Kayleigh Magga nanny
regularly attack the press in briefings
is another culture war component make
this not about the medical facts make it
about fake news and perspective and
point of view
Charlotte Klein gave this example in a
really great piece in Vanity Fair here
is Donald Trump's press secretary
attempting to call out a reporter Jeff
Mason from Reuters for asking whether
it's really safe to go back to church
making it a personal thing where you as
an individual don't like religion take a
look at this incredible strong encourage
every governor to allow their churches
to reopen and boy it's interesting to be
in a room that desperately wants to seem
to see these churches and houses of
worship stay close president debonair
I object to that I mean I go to church
I'm dying to go back to church the
question that we're asking you and would
like to amass the president and dr.
Burke
is in it's safe and if it's not because
the president trying to encourage that
or the president agrees dr. Burke's the
people should we Jeff it is safe to
reopen your churches if you do so in
accordance with the guidelines which are
laid out so the reporter is asking about
the safety of reopening from a medical
perspective and Kaleigh makes it about
Wow look at these leftist loony liberal
atheists reporters who are against
religion and the church component is
particularly transparent with Donald
Trump because Donald Trump has always
been faking his supposed religiosity
he's never been religious he never went
to church he was never against abortion
at 68 years old he decided to run for
president suddenly the Bible's his
favorite book he had an awakening on
abortion because he met a kid he liked
where he learned the mom thought about
getting abortion 20 years prior or
however old the kid was but when he was
asked what passages of the Bible do you
like he said that's personal I'm not
going to talk about that
the 2 Corinthians Fiasco autographing
Bibles for people not exactly showing
deference to the sacred text he was
asked are you an old or new testament
guy just both equally
he doesn't care to know anything about
religion religion is merely the perfect
tool to get people who would never
otherwise have voted for Donald Trump
voting for him despite his moral
failings and now it is a huge part of
amplifying the culture war religious
versus non-religious libertarian versus
you know everybody else when religion
would ideally have no place in a
presidential election or in figuring out
what to do about coronavirus okay so
they're fighting this as a cult culture
work what's the damage done by that
that's really the important question the
damage done by fighting this as a
culture war is that it keeps people more
divided than they actually need to be
the anti-vaxxer Bill Gates conspiracy
people are emboldened by this culture
war they'd be mostly on the sidelines if
it weren't for the amplification of the
culture war the more people
that are angry and divided about
something as empirically definable as a
virus like we know what the virus is
okay we don't know the exact
reproduction rate we their question
marks of course how much contagion is
really happening from surfaces okay but
this is an empirically knowable event
the corona virus they have figured out a
way to get away from the empirical
questions and get to these culture war
type questions and the reason that they
don't want the serious conversations
happening hey how do we reasonably
balance the economy in public health
it's a great question there's a range of
opinions on the left and right they
don't want real conversations happening
between left and right on those on those
issues because they will inevitably be
conversations that lead to the
realization that trump has failed from
day one Trump has to make this a
cultural war we can hope for that the
success he's having making this a
culture war is premature that ultimately
eventually the facts on the ground will
win out but that depends on us that
doesn't depend on him we know what the
strategy is so let's now go from the
cultural war question to one about
rights and responsibilities we talked
about the Trump administration turning
coronavirus into a cultural war because
they have to they're losing on the
science so they're making it a cultural
war now I want to focus in on the
so-called Liberty coronavirus protesters
the people talking about Liberty and
government tyranny as the reasons why
states must open and masks must not be
worn and I need my hair dyed and all of
this stuff they are the ones talking
about why churches and restaurants and
hair salons must all be open right now I
have to tell you I'm sympathetic to
their desires
I'm simp want everything open as soon as
possible I believe we are only needing
to be disclosed because of early
failures by not just the Trump
administration but also many governors I
am skeptical of a total indefinite
shutdown as an even remotely reasonable
thing that could or should extend more
than a minimum amount of time it's bad
for people's mental health it's terrible
for the economy but the
thing is I'm regularly proving my level
of responsibility that would go with the
freedoms that I want and the problem is
that these protesters and the so called
tyranny people regularly prove they
can't be responsible with the freedom
they claim an absolute right to I don't
know if this idea originally came from
Eleanor Roosevelt but she once wrote
quote freedom makes a huge requirement
of every human being with freedom comes
responsibility for the person who is
unwilling to grow up the person who does
not want to carry his own weight this is
a frightening prospect restrictions on
freedom essentially stem from people
abusing freedoms and forcing a
restriction on those so-called freedoms
so let's really dig into it and
understand it first of all I want to be
clear when the gun people for the last
ten years that I've been doing the show
talked to me about government tyranny I
never imagined they were talking about
wearing a mask and staying home to watch
Netflix right that that we never
imagined that's actually what they were
talking about but let's take them at
their word that this is tyranny as they
see it and it's about the economy and
it's about liberty if everyone were
responsible we wouldn't need nearly as
many restrictions when you were talking
about a virus a few people can ruin it
for everybody there's one recent study
which estimated 80% of the spread is
caused by 9% of the people that are
infected in other words most people who
have the virus aren't infecting anyone
they are infecting zero people a small
number of people are infecting a whole
bunch of others now some of these are of
course not irresponsible behavior people
that are causing the spread but many of
them are and so the very people
demanding absolute and total freedom
have in many cases shown no evidence
that they can actually bear the
responsibility that comes with that
freedom the same people demanding
everything reopen are often the people
continuing to have mass gatherings
hosting huge services at their mega
church refusing to wear a mask as some
kind of political statement
the reason governor's had to put in
place restrictions and then stricter
restrictions and then stricter
restrictions is because simply
communicating the facts about the
disease didn't get people to act
responsibly so over time people work
from home masks become a requirement
businesses have to close supermarkets
have to put in place more and more
guidelines parks have to close
they only insist on their rights in a
total vacuum where their
responsibilities are not being met and
aren't even being discussed it is
petulant childish nonsense to simply say
my rights my rights my rights and
pretend that you have no responsibility
to society and in fact it's what Donald
Trump does it's mimicking Trump it's
basically this I wanna I wanna I wanna
stuff and nothing else matters you're
right to get your hair dyed so that your
roots don't show must happen in the
context of ensuring that you're not
getting people sick where there's they
when and where there is a deadly virus
spreading and so then they will shift
their bogus bad faith arguments liberals
want the economy closed they want to
hurt businesses maybe to hurt Donald
Trump in November
find me an actual example with evidence
of someone who makes it clear they want
the economy hurt either for the sake of
hurting the economy or to hurt Donald
Trump or whatever I will be right there
with you and slamming them I've been
clear from day one
Trump has long out state is welcome over
state as welcomed in the White House we
didn't need his coronavirus failings we
don't need a higher death toll to
justify removing Donald Trump in
November I don't want anybody to lose
their business or their job or their
life because of coronavirus for a
political statement but the
irresponsible people who talk only about
their rights as the reason why we are
here today every right comes with
another side of the coin the First
Amendment the right to free speech and
freedom of religion and right to
assemble until your assembling in a way
that infringes on others or using the
speech to incite violence use the right
responsibly the Second Amendment you
have the right to keep and bear arms of
course as long as you behave responsibly
in your life as long as you don't commit
certain
times where you have to forfeit your
right to bear those arms the right comes
with responsibility the freedom of my
fists as the example goes to fly around
stops at your nose and if I don't use
that freedom responsibly I will be in
trouble so every time one of these
protesters is demanding their rights in
a vacuum with no discussion of the
responsibility that they will bring
let's hear from them what responsible
behavior they are bringing to the table
otherwise it's just BS and that's what
we're increasingly seeing make sure you
follow me on twitter at D Pakman and
remember this show has a daily hour-long
podcast if you watch on YouTube for
example you can get the full hour-long
audio podcast we're on stitcher
we're on iTunes we're on Spotify all of
those things subscribe breathe - the
daily audio podcast we'll take a break
and be back after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue chewed calm and use promo code
David you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue to completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com thank you so much the steven
bailey and monica McIlwain both of whom
recently signed up for new memberships
at joined packing.com also thanks to
Katya mallet who's been a member for
five years
today's sustainer of the day grab a
membership at join pakman.com it's quick
it's easy and it really does support the
work that we do so directly Donald Trump
went golfing this weekend as coronavirus
deaths are going to hit a hundred
thousand maybe they already have by the
time you're listening to this maybe they
are minutes from reaching 100,000
American coronavirus deaths that's
happening just weeks after Donald Trump
said the total total total death toll
would be 60,000 and I have to tell you I
understand the outrage I don't really
care about Trump's golf in principle
once again you know this entire Trump
golfing thing has become like so many
other things a proxy or a signal for a
different issue the issue with Trump
golfing is that he's failing at almost
everything and barely does any work he
often watches five hours of cable TV in
the morning strolls into work around
noon or even later if Trump was leading
a world-class coronavirus response and
he was playing golf I wouldn't care who
would really care if the guy was doing a
good job in keeping Americans safe but
he's not and so there's that aspect and
then there's as almost always with
Donald Trump there's the aspect of
incredible double standards and
hypocrisy Trump attacked Barack Obama
for golfing all the time Obama golfed a
fraction of what Trump did and was never
dealing with a global pandemic with a
hundred thousand American death toll one
example back in 2014 Donald Trump
tweeted quote can you believe that with
all of the problems and difficulties
facing the u.s. President Obama spent
the day playing golf and yet Donald
Trump this weekend as we approached the
horrifying number of 100,000 Americans
death dead because of coronavirus and in
May not in June or August as many models
predicted Donald Trump is golfing our
friend Brian class
who's been a guest on the show a couple
of times posted a collage on Twitter of
the many times Trump attacked Obama for
golfing Obama golfing while the TSA
falls apart
Obama golfing you know while a marine is
in Mexico Obama golfing during Ebola
during which two people died so this is
not really about playing golf this is
about Trump's failures this is about
Trump's hypocrisy and this is about from
sley thil incompetence Trump ran on I'm
gonna be too busy too rarely if ever
leave the White House when I'm President
of the United States but he's golfed
more than anybody Trump criticized his
predecessor for golfing even in the
absence of anything even remotely
approximating a global pandemic never
mind a global pandemic on which he has
failed Trump said Obama shouldn't be
golfing when two people died so I don't
need the golfing to stop I need the
dangerous incompetence and hypocrisy to
end acting more quickly would have saved
so many lives getting a working testing
and contact tracing program in place
would have saved so many lives there's a
new study from Columbia University which
says that just one week earlier for
shutting down restaurants and businesses
could have saved 35,000 of the hundred
thousand that have died so far thirty
five out of the hundred thousand study
from the University of Southern
California over the last few days found
similar numbers made similar estimates
looking at how South Korea responded I
mean I'm like a broken record at this
point looking at South Korea is very
very relevant so yeah I mean the Golf
Club trips to his own clubs funnel money
into his family's pockets he's violating
the emoluments clause secret service by
renting all of those golf carts and then
paying Trump's own business for those
golf carts is just a way for Trump to
profit from his presidency it's not just
this way that he's violating the
emoluments clause that doesn't change
the taxpayers are paying for I get all
of it but the golf in and of itself is
not the issue it's the hypocrisy and the
degree to which Trump's incompetence and
laziness is now leading to
a very real death toll six-figure death
toll in the United States alone and he
is continuing to golf despite
criticizing his predecessor for doing it
and saying he wouldn't be golfing
it's the presidency that has to end let
him play all the golf he wants he can
play 36 72 holes a day if he wants once
we've removed him from office okay I
want to talk now about this issue of
churches at the top of the show I talked
to you about how the corona virus
pandemic in the United States is now a
culture war it's not really a fight for
the best ideas about how to deal with
the virus while taking care of the
economy that would be the right thing to
do it's merely a cultural war now thanks
to the Trump administration thanks to
Trump's fixation on opening churches and
opening them right away we also now have
to talk a little bit more specifically
about the houses of worship component
but I just want to recontextualize the
church's thing is one piece of the
broader culture war that coronavirus is
now about it's not about public health
let's talk about the legal element of
the church openings Donald Trump said
late last week governors must must must
at his Direction designate houses of
worship as essential organizations so
that they are allowed to reopen in
places where they have been closed and
Donald Trump even said if governors
don't determine that churches are
essential
I will override governors and make sure
that churches are deemed essential let's
look at this this is from a press
briefing late last week Trump bailed
without taking any questions after
saying the following I know them well
they love their congregations they love
their people they don't want anything
bad to happen to them or to anybody else
the governors need to do the right thing
and allow these very important essential
places of faith to open right now for
this weekend if they don't do it I will
override the governor's
in America we need more prayer not less
thank you very much thank you so there
are multiple layers to this first is the
question our houses of worship really
essential okay now I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be exceedingly fair on this issue
houses of worship are not essential to
the economy houses of worship are not
essential to public health and they are
not essential to life
you don't need churches like you need a
grocery store because without food you
die but I understand
culturally that churches are seen as
essential by religious folks I don't see
it that way but I know many people do
that's why this is the perfect issue for
Trump to focus on in order to wage
coronavirus as a cultural war its
perspective if you think that the most
important thing for Humanity is making
sure that you are praying in the right
place and that your religion is what's
holding society together you're going to
be difficult to convince that churches
aren't essential and that's why this is
the perfect way for Trump to wage
coronavirus as a cultural war then we
have the public health component if
restaurants can't yet be open to dine in
how do you justify churches being open
you can dine in at a restaurant much
more safely and in much less time than
you can go to a church on the average
you can social distance theoretically in
a restaurant and you can social distance
theoretically in a church but you can
get in and out of a restaurant very
quickly compared to how long people tend
to be in churches restaurants at full
capacity sometimes only accommodate 15
20 or 25 people small restaurants I'm
talking about churches are almost always
at least 50 people sometimes hundreds
sometimes thousands sometimes tens of
thousands at these mega churches we know
of churches being super spreaders where
they have one service and a ton of
people end up infected because of one
person
so from a public health perspective
there is no way that you can defend
churches being open when restaurants are
still closed for dining lastly and maybe
most importantly let's focus on the
legal Trump says he will Oh
ride governor's he can't do it he does
not have that authority it doesn't
actually matter by the way that he can't
do it and I'm gonna tell you why in a
second but from a legal perspective
Trump often talks about federalism
federalism just means a system with a
federal government and also subsequent
either state or provincial government
that's all that means state or
provincial governments in the United
States it is outlined in the Tenth
Amendment and the Tenth Amendment lays
out the default power dynamics between
state and federal government where it
says quote the powers not delegated to
the United States by the Constitution
nor prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the States respectively or
to the people so in other words if there
is some action or power that the
Constitution or Bill of Rights don't
specifically say the federal government
has power over this and the Constitution
and Bill of Rights don't ban states from
having power over that the default is
states decide about that issue
designation of churches as essential or
non-essential is not a power given to
the federal government and it is not a
power from which states are restricted
thus federalism and the Tenth Amendment
confirm that Trump has no authority
whatsoever
full-stop black and white period to
determine what types of entities are
essential from the perspective of states
that is really the the analysis that's
required we don't need to go further now
to finish this up it doesn't actually
matter politically that Trump has no
authority to force governor's to sage
churches are essential because by merely
saying this Donald Trump has already
virtue signaled he has called for
churches to be designated as essential
he has claimed that we hope he will
override governor's that's really all
that matters if you are at rumpus from a
section of the religious Trump voters
you don't care that he won't actually
override governor's you don't care that
he can't override governor's he has said
what he needed to say he says he wants
to override governor's
and that he believes churches should
open right away that's it
it's virtuous siglent signaling at its
worst the right is quick to criticize
virtue signaling when they see it from
the left this is absolutely the worst of
the worst virtue signaling signaling
lastly what Trump could do or what he
could try is to withhold money from
States if they don't do what he wants it
would be sick it would be immoral I
don't know whether it would be legal but
Trump has already threatened Michigan
and Nevada about withholding money if
they do vote by mail that he could
absolutely threaten whether he would do
it whether he could do it is a further
question to which we don't have an
answer right now we're gonna continue
covering this story on the show's
Instagram at David Pakman show
also I am having a rabbit Fiasco in my
backyard I'm going to talk about it on
today's bonus show but you can also
follow the the craziness on my personal
Instagram at David Pakman plus on my
personal Instagram the most popular post
I've ever made to Instagram it's me
holding a puppy over the weekend just me
holding a puppy nothing else and it is
exploding on my Instagram page follow me
at David Packard great much more
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18 welcome back to the David
Pakman show so last week I did a story
called the conspiracy theorists are
winning and in that story I explained
that even with only a small percentage
of support for some of these wild
conspiracy theories about coronavirus
vaccination or Bill Gates or the virus
or whatever it's more than enough to
wreak havoc and cause chaos and prevent
the greater population at large from
dealing with the virus in the most
logical and efficient way possible and
that part of it happens because the mere
introduction of some of these conspiracy
theories can sometimes take over media
outlets it can start to occupy time
where we're hearing about conspiracy
theories even if they are being debunked
rather than hearing from medical experts
and public health officials and the like
and so what has happened is that the
conspiracy theorists have gotten just
enough pick up in the general public and
in media that they are very successfully
creating a distraction
from actual science-based discussions
about what we are dealing with in a
global pandemic I underestimated how bad
it's gotten we now have a new poll from
Yahoo News and YouGov which actually
connects belief in these conspiracy
theories to how it's going to affect us
in dealing with the virus over the long
term and the numbers are horrifying so
I'll give you some of the data 44% of
Republicans believe that Bill Gates is
planning to use a corona virus vaccine
as a pretext to implant microchips in
billions of people and monitor their
movements now what's hilarious about
that is everybody's carrying around a
phone with GPS and there are much
simpler ways if one believed that this
was ultimately the goal of people like
Bill Gates there are much them
ways than micro tripping them with
injectable microchips under the guise of
a corona virus vaccine but they seem to
not care about that or not know about
that or whatever now I really want you
to not fall short of understanding this
insanity nearly half of all Republicans
think Bill Gates wants to microchip
people with a corona virus vaccine
that's if you went to many psychiatrists
with that belief they would medicate you
for paranoid delusions it's as simple as
that
now shockingly even 19% of Democrats
believe the same conspiracy theory and
I've told you before you know
anti-vaxxer nonsense exists on both left
and right
typically for different reasons your
right-wing anti-vaxxers tend to be
motivated by distrust of government
government is going to make me get a
vaccine or manipulate my brain chemistry
with a vaccine or whatever the left-wing
anti-vaxxers often are sort of motivated
by distrust of pharmaceutical companies
but they often end up believing very
very similar nonsense these beliefs are
very stratified around coronavirus by
political ideology so for example among
those who say they mostly get their news
from fox news 50% believe Bill Gates and
the microchip conspiracy theory 44% of
those who voted for Trump believe the
Bill Gates microchip conspiracy theory
however only 15% of MSNBC viewers
believe the Bill Gates microchip
conspiracy theory only 12% of Hillary
Clinton voters believe it so two
important things here first of all this
is not a disagreement over I don't know
it's taxing the rich good or bad for the
economy this is not a theoretical debate
about should the Constitution be
interpret interpreted for modern times
or only literally as it was written in
the 18th century okay this is a
medically consequential lethal belief
that some people hold it is very part of
it is very one-sided one side has
science on their side the other side
does not this is not a joke this is not
a drill this is really where we are
right now there is one side Fox News
viewers Trump voters Republicans that
believe this absolute trash to an
alarming degree now the repercussions
Hillary Clinton voters are thirty points
more likely to get vaccinated or to say
they are going to get vaccinated
then our Trump voters understand those
numbers 72 percent of Hillary voters say
they will get the vaccine when it is out
only 44 percent of Trump voters say they
will get the corona virus vaccine if and
when it is available so in total right
now when you blend Hillary and Trump
voters and all that stuff only 50% of
the country right now says they plan to
get the corona virus vaccine why is that
a horrifying number because it's not
enough for herd immunity based on so the
required herd immunity is based on the
reproduction rate of the virus measles
is so contagious that it's believed to
require between a 92 and 95 percent
vaccination or immunity rate to get hurt
immunity corona virus is less contagious
than measles but we believe you need 70%
vaccination and immunity to have herd
immunity if only 50% get the vaccine you
need another 20% of the country to be
infected and recover to get immunity
that would translate to roughly 600,000
additional deaths from that group that
will not get vaccinated once a vaccine
is available those are horrifying
horrifying numbers by the way again I I
don't want to ignore this before moving
on a lot of the same people who will
potentially not get a vaccine that could
save their life or the life of another
because they think Bill Gates is going
to microchip them to track their
movement they uncritically carry around
a phone which has their location data
knows their interactions with products
and brands their preferences gives them
a
tailored and customized series of ads
likely to manipulate their purchasing
behavior but they're worried Bill Gates
will do this roundabout thing of getting
a corona virus vaccine that will let
them be microchip will let Bill Gates
microchip them so he can track them it's
crazy it's crazy and it is very very
much split among partisan lines okay I
want to now do a little bit of a deep
dive into a recent poll this is an
utterly devastating poll for Donald
Trump with the normal caveats it's May
things can change very quickly between
now and November look at how quickly
they changed for Joe Biden within 72
hours after the South Carolina primary
now there is a Fox News poll that says
Trump is losing forty eight to forty to
Joe Biden right now I know some of you
will say David a Fox News poll what the
hell are you doing that that's crazy
Fox News why do we care Fox News polling
is its own enterprise they are well
ranked as far as polling goes and they
were pretty accurate back in 2016
538 ranks two different Fox News polling
partnerships as in either a - or a /b so
Fox News polling is actually pretty
reliable it's very different than what
you hear on their airwaves on the
question of Trump versus Biden
nationally Joe Biden has an eight-point
lead forty eight to forty Trump is
winning among men and Trump is winning
among whites losing a ton of other
important split so Trump is losing women
to Joe Biden Trump is losing black and
Hispanic voters Trump is losing all
non-white voters Trump is losing people
under 45 Trump is losing people over 45
Trump is losing people earning under
$50,000 a year and people earning more
than $50,000 a year but there's
something really interesting when you
look at some of the other splits
according to this poll four percent of
Democrats plan to vote for Trump and
eight percent of Republicans plan to
vote for Biden understand that if 2016
essentially holds with the one change of
four percent of Democrats abandoned the
Democratic Party in vote Trump eight
percent of
look ins abandoned Trump and vote for
Joe Biden that's all you need to flip a
bunch of states I'll give you just one
example we're gonna use Hillary and
Trump 2016 numbers to think about this
so in Wisconsin in 2016 Hillary Clinton
lost by just under twenty three thousand
votes each candidate got about 1.4
million votes Trump just over 1.4
million Clinton just under 1.3 million
so this is very simple math you take 4%
of Hillary's votes from 2016 and
assigned them to Trump you take 8% of
trumps votes and imagine that they went
to Hillary or you know potentially they
would go to Joe Biden that alone would
have given Hillary Clinton a 91,000 vote
victory in Wisconsin instead of a loss
so that is just one state it is just one
example but understand this idea that we
basically maintain 2016 if four percent
of Democrats switch and eight percent of
Republicans switch Trump loses Trump
loses now I want to make it again
I know people said David what a you know
these disclaimers maybe aren't necessary
they are necessary right now we have a
long way to go this is a snapshot of
right now if the perception of the
economy improves by November if the
perception of how things are going with
coronavirus improves by November we may
very very quickly see this these numbers
reverse dramatically we must all vote we
must all get out the vote etc lastly
just one other thing on issues Trump is
always in these polls strongest on the
economy Trump is still stronger than
Biden on the economy in this latest Fox
News poll but it's by a far narrower
margin than we've seen throughout
Trump's presidency lastly on China Trump
in great part ran not just on I'll fix
the economy even though the economy was
doing quite well when Trump was running
Trump ran on I know how to deal with
China I know how to deal with trade
right now Joe Biden is polling as more
trustworthy on China that is one of
Trump's primary issues alongside this
amorphous
hissing economic issues that he tends to
do well on those issue based numbers are
very very important let me know what you
think make sure you are subscribed to
the daily David Pakman show audio
podcast get it on iTunes stitcher or any
podcast app that you prefer we'll be
back after this with some interesting
videos to play for you some interesting
beats and much more the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
today we will reach the unconscionable
tragic milestone of 100,000 dead
americans from coronavirus their that is
a number we may have already reached by
the time you listen to today's show or
watch today's program and that is a
number that we have reached with
widespread now allegations of data
suppression in a number of different
states which i will discuss with you on
tomorrow's program but it we've already
passed 100,000 is the point whether we
officially get there today or yesterday
or tomorrow we actually have passed that
number sometime ago due to the believed
suppression and a mischaracterization of
some deaths and as this is going on the
president of the united states has been
tweeting allegations that a TV host
murdered someone without any evidence
and donald trump also tweeted or
retweeted a tweet calling hillary
clinton a skank but today i want to talk
about these murder smears that donald
trump has been making against MSNBC's
joe scarborough Donald Trump tweeting
quote a lot of interest in this story
about psycho Joe Scarborough so a young
marathon runner just happened to faint
in his office hit her head on his desk
and died I would think that there is a
lot more to this story than that an
affair what about the so-called
investigator Reid story Trump also
tweeted a blow to her head body found
under his desk left Congress suddenly
big topic of discussion in Florida and
he's a nut job with bad ratings
keep digging use forensic geniuses so
what this all relates to is a Joe
Scarborough staffer that died in 2001
was a 28 year old woman lori class Udhas
and conspiracy theories started about
her death pretty quickly down in Florida
and this is 19 years ago Trump is now
reviving this and giving it oxygen Media
Mia merely because he is in a media
battle with Joe Scarborough because he
doesn't like joe scarborough's coverage
of donald trump on MSNBC that's all that
this is
but the president is accusing a meet
host he does not like of murder even
many Republicans are disgusted by this
Illinois Republican Rep Adam Kinzinger
tweeted quote completely unfounded
conspiracy just stop stop spreading it
stop creating paranoia it will destroy
us Fox News bomb-thrower Brit Hume even
tweeting quote 30,000 retweets for this
discredited tale based on a three year
old post from some wingding web site
this is why even his critics should want
Trump
to play a lot of golf because when he
does he's not tweeting crap like this so
the analysis here is 90% obvious and I
want to focus on the 10% that maybe is
less obvious of course in that 90% yes
this is not normal yes the world is
laughing and crying and pitying us yes
Trump accusing people of murder on
Twitter is an absolute and total horror
as 100,000 people have died of
coronavirus in the United States with as
many as 2/3 of those deaths preventable
with just a couple week earlier call for
national stay at home orders the only
remaining question is why Trump is still
allowed on Twitter and I got a lot of
emails over the weekend from from you
guys saying David you know Trump is he's
specifically targeting someone with
false allegations with a conspiracy
theory that person Joe Scarborough is
being bullied now Joe Scarborough is
getting death threats and how is this
how is Twitter allowing this what you
have to understand is Twitter has very
specific rules for what you can and
can't say but they have different rules
for famous people in politicians and
Twitter put out rules last year I
believe it was which I'm characterizing
it in the way I see it you can read the
full text of it if you want if a world
leader or a politician tweets something
that would normally violate their policy
like for example in this case Trump is
targeting an individual for mass
bullying like Trump did by saying Joe
Scarborough might have murdered someone
if it's Trump if they leave it up
because the mere fact that it's Trump
who said it makes it newsworthy in a way
where it's newsworthiness and the fact
that it will be reported on necessitates
leaving it up so that it can be properly
reported on is is sort of the gist to it
and I understand that but Twitter can
also say make the news elsewhere right
it's not what we want our community to
be used for making news about imagine
being the family of twenty then twenty
eight-year-old Laurie class Udhas you've
been trying to recover from an
inconceivably traumatic event that took
place 19 years ago where your 28 year
old family member died and in comes the
President of the United States
retweeting a three-year-old conspiracy
article from a nonsense website all
because he doesn't like joe
scarborough's coverage of him
this is an era listen the Trump era is
going to be an era where number one we
should never forgive the Trump
administration nor the people who voted
to put him in power but as a country
hopefully at some point we fix this
atrocity hopefully it's in five months
it might not be until four years and
five months which would be tragic I hope
eventually the world is able to forget
the United States as a country I'm not
saying forgive the Trump voters and I'm
certainly not saying forgive Trump in
his administration but I hope I hope
that at some point the world will
forgive us as a country for this
absolute aberration that hopefully will
only last for years but may last eight
years if we don't take care of business
on November 3rd so yesterday was
Memorial Day here in the United States
Donald Trump was at a wreath laying
ceremony and I got a ton of emails and a
bunch of articles I read arguing that
Donald Trump was visibly struggling to
stand at a Memorial Day event and that
there is this sort of weird way
which Trump seems to be off-balance and
regularly recalibrating his balance so
I'm not gonna spend a ton of time on
this if you know my show you know we've
covered Trump's strange behavior whose
sources we've never yet determined we've
not yet determined and I'm going to talk
about that a little bit let's let's
first look at the videos and then I'll
tell you what I think here's one video
during a rendition yesterday of the
national anthem and Donald Trump does
seem unable to just stand up straight
his whole whole upper torso is sort of
rocking forward forward and back as he's
in a salute position and it wasn't a
windy day reports are that wind was only
four miles per hour no one else is
swaying in that way and that was the
source of some of the concern here is
another video from yesterday in which
Donald Trump walks up to a wreath and is
staring at it and again he's kind of
swaying in the wind sort of swaying back
and forth and he does at moments seem
like he's going in the direction of
falling over but his balance system
realizes it and compensates by pulling
him back so I want to be like a hundred
and ten percent crystal clear this could
be something or it could be nothing and
we've sinned we've seen this type of
stuff since day one with Trump these
inner ear balance type issues can be
related to all sorts of different things
in earlier stages sometimes even before
other dementia symptoms develop starting
to have issues balancing when standing
or walking can suggest an increased
potential to develop Alzheimer's or
other types of dementia balance issues
can be related to medication side
effects people speculate that Trump
takes stimulants stimulants can
certainly affect your balance but they
can also simply affect your ability to
sit still because you're energized in
this way that uppers stimulants and
amphetamines can can do this could also
be Trump's weird stance I know some of
you are aware that Trump stands in a
very weird way kind of hinged forward at
the at the hips um that might make it
difficult to stand still there's
speculation that Trump stands that way
because he wears lifts in his
Jews which sort of lean him forward what
we know is this is not new what we know
is it wasn't windy yesterday Trump
wasn't getting blown around by wind so
if you say to me do I think something is
up here big picture you all know I think
some things up and I don't know if the
video from yesterday is part of it or if
it's something new or if it's nothing if
you say do I really care well I care if
it's something that's impacting Trump's
cognition because he's the President of
the United States whether or not
something like this explains Trump's
behaviors and actions Trump has failed
either way right
like the coronavirus response has been a
failed response whether or Trump has
dementia an inner ear issue is abusing
drugs or whatever the case may be it
could be ADHD right I mean if maybe
Trump can't stand still but does a good
job because he has ADHD and it's hard
for him to stand still who cares right
the point is he's not doing a good job
and he can't stand still and looks
unstable and looks confused and got off
of Air Force One and didn't recognize
his own limo in front of him and
wandered off until a Secret Service
agent brought him back holding him is
that why he's a bad president no he'd be
a terrible president no matter what the
explanation is does it aggravate the
lethality of this presidency yeah yeah
it probably does will we ever know
what's really going on here I don't know
I you know inside the Reagan White House
they knew while he was president that he
was starting to show signs and symptoms
of Alzheimer's it was learned sort of
officially publicly later only in
retrospect did people start figuring out
that it was not something that happened
only after he was out of office he was
experiencing symptoms while he was in
office my instinct is we probably would
not get anything definitive about Trump
while he is in office it is yet another
reason to get him out in November
meaning he would leave in January rather
than giving him another four years
hopefully someday we
you know exactly what it is that is
going on we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a voicemail about mail-in voting a
very important topic this election cycle
take a listen hey we need to push the
mail-in vote regardless of what he says
in numbers we need to push the mail vote
absolutely agree
listen twenty twenty could come down to
mail in voting we we just don't know
what the state of the pandemic is going
to be in november if the numbers
continue to decline between now and then
we could have a safe ish situation to go
out and vote in person in november but
there are still going to be people that
will be scared and rightfully so because
we are not going to eradicate this in
any significant way maybe ever I mean it
might become just a seasonal thing where
you have to manage it with a seasonal
coronavirus vaccine we just don't know
but it will still be here in some
capacity in November if we are in the
middle of a second wave in November then
waiting on setting up vote-by-mail is
going to be too late there will be
States who won't be able to do it it'll
be a disaster so the caller could not be
more right we need to be pushing for
vote-by-mail now and fortunately some
states are doing it now even places like
Texas at least for now
are allowing anybody who wants an
absentee ballot to get an absentee
ballot and it's valid to say the reason
I want one is I'm afraid of getting
coronavirus that is valid even in Texas
right now but depending on the numbers
by November it may no longer apply to
the November presidential election
understand that Trump has no federal
authority to ban vote-by-mail Trump also
has no federal authority to designate
churches essential organizations or
whatever the case may be but that
doesn't mean Trump isn't going to run
propaganda on this he's already been
pushing vote-by-mail leads to voter
fraud it's not true the data don't
suggest it don't demonstrate it in any
way whatsoever but we are starting to
see low
cool Republican officials take a cue
from Trump and start to say it causes
fraud it opens the door to fraud blah
blah blah blah blah let's not allow them
to do that
let's lobby all of our states to say at
minimum it doesn't we're not saying
right now cancel in-person voting but
we're just we don't need to do that all
we need is a rule that says if you want
to vote by mail you can and you will not
have to justify it because you're out of
state you will not you can just request
an absentee ballot period better is we
will send everyone an application for an
absentee ballot which they have to
return to get an absentee ballot even
better is we will send everyone an
actual absentee ballot now different
states have different rules about what's
allowed in terms of automatically
sending people absentee ballots versus
well you can't do that you've got to
send them an application every state is
different it's a patchwork of 50
different elections let's go for the
gold which is send everybody an absentee
ballot and let them vote by mail if not
send everybody an absentee ballot
application if not let everybody request
an absentee ballot for any reason even
if it doesn't meet the previously
established requirements for why one
would get an absentee ballot we can do
this and one last thing on this I'm
spending more time on this than I plan
to but this is important it only really
matters in a few states right I mean
listen California whether they vote by
mail or not Biden's gonna win California
Massachusetts Biden's going to win
Massachusetts Utah Trump's going to win
Utah I think although I actually saw one
poll which says it's not as out of reach
for Biden as you might imagine but
Trump's likely going to go to win Utah
we need to focus our efforts in
particular states Republicans know this
right we're talking about Pennsylvania
Florida Ohio Michigan Wisconsin I'm not
getting all of them that's where we need
to focus our efforts we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today I
will recap my appearance on the Joe
Rogan experience last week I have a new
rabbit problem you are not going to
believe what I have dealt with over the
last 48 hours some of you will some of
you won't and also we will talk about a
rat problem rat
are finding less trash to eat because a
lot of commercial spaces that generate
huge amounts of trash are essentially
closed not generating trash rats are
becoming cannibalistic because of the
trash shortage due to coronavirus all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
don't miss it sign up at join
hackman.com and I will see you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video